the Dan Patrick show brought to you by
the 2018 Mercedes AMG e-class with a
suite of innovative technologies one of
the most intelligent cars on the road go
to MBUSA com visit your local dealership
to schedule your test drive today he was
a hit the last time he was on the
program Jaylon Smith the Cowboys
linebacker joining us after the win
against the Seattle Seahawks how you
feeling today I'm feeling great very
energized for for a new week do you
celebrate it again do you celebrate
after win like that man anytime you win
in the National Football League regular
season postseason like you have to
embrace it
luckily we you know my brother and I we
had some family in town we had our dad
in town so we got a chance to spend a
lot of time with him and your brother is
a rod to backup running back on the
Cowboys when you're facing Russell
Wilson like the difference in facing
Russell Wilson as opposed to other
quarterbacks is what he's so elusive he
can extend plays outside of the pocket
he can even extend plays inside of the
pocket and our objective was to you know
contain that as much as possible were
you surprised that they were going to
continue to run the ball as much as they
did no because you know like much other
successful teams it's all about
establishing the run you don't want to
make your team one-dimensional so the
more we could stop the run and you know
kind of force the Seahawks to throw the
ball the better our chances for sure
yeah I was surprised I thought that they
would have the ball in Russell Wilson's
hands more were you guys surprised at
that no when you understand this game of
football a comes down to running the
ball because there's so many things that
you can do off of that play-action
misdirection you know different type of
gadget plays so that's really the heart
that it comes down to me you can even
though you talk about all of these great
quarterbacks they want to establish or
drag one because
is opening a pocket well talking to
Jaylon Smith the Cowboys linebacker
Notre Dame gret by the way how much
grief did you take with the Irish
getting blown out yeah
college player okay I took a lot of
Greece that my words was all about
revenge getting revenge getting back to
the big big dance and we failed but
that's okay you know there's there's
still Irish fear for sure you grew up a
patriot fan again you grew up a New
England Patriot fan
I did I did Mike Vrabel was my favorite
player but I'm walk out boys man did you
meet bramble yes I met on my senior high
school the heat was the defensive line
coach at Ohio State so he was recruiting
me and I got a chance to meet him and
you know do a little running around
together it was it was fun wait he
couldn't close you know ha we were just
working out but you could okay so you go
to Notre Dame now I heard the story that
you worked at a Burger King now did you
in high school
yeah my senior year yeah I I worked at
Burger King but my second semester how
good were you man I would be least I'm
telling you I was always a play out of
about three months in a row I really
wanted to I really wanted to understand
you know what people at fast-food
restaurants in through your honor mean
and just understanding the different
dynamics of it and one of my passions is
you know putting a smile on people's
faces so I was able to do that a lot for
sure yeah but you're not you don't want
to put a smile on Jared gulfs face this
weekend
no no more in a more to sad way you know
you know congratulations after the game
and good luck moving on we definitely
want to get the win for sure did you do
drive-through at Burger King I did it
all
did you eat a lot of Burger King man
those Oreo shakes and they were they
were to death for me they might have
lost money by having you work there as
much as you probably ate you did your
brother work there as well no my brother
worked at ed at a YMCA his senior year
you were smart to work at Burger King
yeah like I said I wanted to get the
fast-food experience of this
understanding you know just a different
dynamics being on the opposite side you
know of the counter so I really really
learned a lot you know so I'm I'm
thankful for it for sure
what do you how much is it helpful
helping you that you already played the
Rams man it helps a little bit because
you understand the tempo you understand
the type of caliber offers that they
that they run but it's a new year it's a
new defense for us you know as far as
just our personnel and the tenacity if
we play with so we're looking for to
this this great challenge there they got
to some unique guys there so we're
looking forward to getting up there to
LA well congrats so far good luck going
to Los Angeles there and we appreciate
your time as always jaylen I appreciate
it hope you're watching this
oh I will be I will be Thank You jaylen
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
you